if you guys are regular viewers of our
channel you will already know that we
come out with tons of elon and tesla
videos this is because we absolutely
love what that man is doing with his
super successful car brand and we truly
believe that tesla will be a global
powerhouse very soon so here we are back
at it again with another video on elon
musk and tesla if you are also impressed
by elon at some level you will want to
stick around as we are going to discuss
something very juicy in this video do me
a favor look back a decade did you ever
imagine that self-driving cars would be
a reality on our roads or that humanity
could possibly consider taking a trip to
mars in another few years i don't think
any of us did well we all know about
spacex's mars mission but did you know
that elon and tesla just made another
giant stride in the field of
self-driving cars with their new
partnership with samsung today we will
explore that new partnership with
samsung which will be manufacturing
tesla's new self-driving chip and why
this has the potential of being another
game changer we all know that tesla's
autopilot technology is still one of the
best in its class it is a system that
has been developed and thoroughly user
tested in commercial models but over the
last few years other manufacturers have
slowly caught up to it many other car
companies have started following tesla's
example and started dabbling in this
space with launches such as the infiniti
qx50 or the kia k5 these car companies
have not only given intense competition
to tesla but also managed to improve on
certain self-driving technology so with
this new samsung deal elon and the
engineers at tesla are planning for
another quantum leap that will allow
them to outperform their rivals once
again as you'll discover over the course
of this video this is something that is
years in the making and if it goes
according to elon's plan then fully
self-driving cars will be a reality in
just a few more years elon first
announced this in 2019 at an investor
conference and since then work has begun
between the two companies to get the new
hw 4.0 chip and its associated systems
ready by 2022. although it is not
confirmed yet the new hw 4.0 chip is
widely expected to be introduced in the
tesla cyber truck which will begin
delivery in late 2022 so what is this
new chip all about and how can switching
to a new chip manufacturer help tesla
let us explore tesla cars were the first
to include the autopilot feature in its
commercial models all the way back in
2014. in those days autopilot relied on
a series of cameras and radar technology
to process its surroundings all of the
gathered data was fed into tesla's
proprietary computer vision software
which then used a chip inside the car's
computer to do all the heavy
calculations keeping your car within the
white lines of the highway but after
seven strong years of development and
user testing autopilot technology has
advanced leaps and bounds the system has
become so efficient that tesla announced
in its 2021 ai day that it is dropping
the radar altogether instead the new
tesla vision system will utilize just
cameras and an ai neural net to keep the
cars on track bringing us ever closer to
the promise of fully self-driving cars
what is a neural net you wonder well
simply put it's a hive mind of
artificial intelligence the idea is to
reflect the behavior of the human brain
allowing computer programs to recognize
patterns and solve problems using ai and
machine learning for its cars tesla is
in the process of developing a neural
net that when trained and scaled up
properly can predict all types of
driving scenarios make split-second
decisions based on road and traffic
conditions and constantly learn to
improve itself over time this massive
undertaking was made possible due to a
lawn development process inside tesla
that has as much to do with the software
side of things as it is to do with the
rapid development of chips capable of
training the ai and running those
massive calculations in split seconds
and this is where the new partnership
with samsung comes in from the very
beginning of the company elon has stated
his vision of creating totally
self-driving vehicles and has moved
stridently to innovate in this field of
ai so since 2016 tesla has been pouring
resources into its own in-house r d team
for neural net development and chip
making this led to the development of
its first fully self-driving chip or fsd
in 2019 which is the basis for the hw
3.0 chipset used in the current models
of tesla cars the fsd packs in 6 billion
transistors and includes an integrated
neural network processor gpu safety
systems and security system for the
later models of the fsd samsung provided
the system on a chip or soc which is
essentially the entire integrated
circuit or ic around the chip this was a
major upgrade from tesla's previous
nvidia chips offering 21 times greater
performance in a smaller footprint this
upgrade by samsung has played an
important role in reducing costs while
maintaining the performance and range of
newer generation tesla cars now in 2021
tesla's internal chip development team
has come up with a new model called the
d1 or dojo chip and samsung will again
help tesla manufacture these newer
generations of chips and socs the d1
processor packs a whopping 50 billion
transistors and delivers 362 teraflops
of power it is an application specific
integrated circuit or asic built upon
samsung's 7 nanometer node technology to
be clear the d1 chip in its current form
will not be used in the final production
cars their purpose is twofold first they
will be used in massive networks to
train machine learning models within
tesla which will form the basis of the
new tesla vision system software and
neural network and second their
technology will be used as a blueprint
by samsung to manufacture the hw 4.0
chips which will be mounted in the new
tesla car models and run the vision
system software to self-drive the cars
in a nutshell tesla in collaboration
with samsung has managed to create the
most powerful supercomputer solely
dedicated to training a neural network
that will make self-driving cars a
reality on the road soon people in the
industry are already touting the d1
chips as a game changer in computing
performance and their ability to train
large neural networks is second to none
the way these supercomputers work is 354
connected neural training nodes make a
d1 chip 25 connected d1 chips make a
training tile 12 training tiles makes a
cabinet and 10 cabinets make the exopod
which is the name of this supercomputer
exopod has the capability of providing
1.1 e-flaps which is 1100 teraflops for
processing power which is an insane
amount plus its high bandwidth low
latency architecture allows it to
perform four times better than any other
ai supercomputer at the same cost while
keeping the carbon footprint five times
smaller and saving more energy this
massive amount of processing power is
crucial to rapidly training tesla's ai
neural networks which will eventually
end up driving the new generation of
cars from 2022 onwards think of exopod
as an ascent hive mind that when trained
properly can reach a level of autonomy
where it can constantly communicate with
all tesla cars all over the globe
helping them navigate the streets while
you relax in your seat not just that the
great thing about machine learning and
neural networks is that it is a
perpetual learning loop so at the same
time as it is helping cars around the
world it is also absorbing vast sums of
data from these cars to build up its
knowledge even further with this
collaboration with samsung it seems that
elon is well on his way to making that a
reality fulfilling the promise of fully
self-driving cars on the road maybe even
before the end of this decade now in all
honesty this is just the start of the
association and it will still take years
to realize that dream but nonetheless
the new samsung manufactured tesla h 4.0
chip which will most likely get mounted
into the new cyber truck is an
exponential jump in performance that is
bound to come with some unique features
that we haven't seen in other tesla
models yet i for one cannot wait to see
what they are and what elon and tesla
have in store for us next we will keep
following the story as it unfolds so
make sure you subscribe to the channel
and ring the notification bell to get
notified the next time we release
another video and if you are a huge fan
of elon and tesla just like us smash
that like button and share some of that
love our way as well till then from all
of us here at simply tech have a great
day ahead and see you in the next video